hey guys it's Jenna here I love snacks
and I do enjoy checking thumb up if you
do well munches we got to make sure that
our snacks are healthy without packing
on high amount of extra calories which
may leave you feeling bloated or
regretful in the morning so be sure to
watch this video through add it to your
favourite playlist because I'm going to
share with you three ingredient vegan
healthy snack bites really really easy
no baking or cooking is required and you
can make them in less than five minutes
trust me you would want to eat the
entire batch after taking your first
bite so we want if you need a quick and
easy to consume pre or post-workout
snack with protein and carbs then you
got to make these mini protein cupcakes
the three wholesome ingredients which
will nourish your body for a good
workout are one cup of rolled oats two
scoops of protein powder and one large
banana sliced add oats and protein
powder into a food processor process
very quickly just until the oats are
slightly chopped but not completely
smooth then add the banana and continue
to process until well combined transfer
the mixture evenly into 12 mini cupcake
liners store them in a container and
freeze them up before consuming allow
them to defrost for about five minutes
if you want to bring them out with you
then choose to pick them in the oven for
about 10 to 15 minutes a serving of
three mini cupcakes contain 167 calories
15 gram of protein and 23 gram of carbs
a really great pre or post-workout snack
you can even Jessop this basic recipe
and mix in some dried fruits chopped
nuts or seeds I'm sure most of you have
come across the three ingredient energy
bar I'm going to also share this with
you because it is so versatile and you
can keep making it with different
ingredients this recipe calls for three
basic ingredients 1 cup of dates prunes
or figs because they are sticky the
other main ingredient to hold the
mixture together
I used prunes one cup of
fruits of your choice this will give you
the chewy texture and natural sweetness
I used goji berries and one cup of nuts
or seeds of your choice this is to add
crunchiness into the bar I opted for
sunflower seeds in a food processor add
in the prunes and process until they
begin to form a paste then mix in the
goji berries and sunflower seeds
continue to process very quickly just to
combine the ingredients the mixture may
loosen up with the addition of fruits
and nuts and the texture will be chunky
but that's okay transfer the mixture
onto a parchment-lined pan and press
down firmly to form a thick square
because my pan is rather large I will
only use half of it use a clean wrap
because the mixture is very sticky wrap
and chill in the fridge for about 1 to 2
hours or until firm once firm cuts into
12 even bars store these energy bars in
the fridge until ready for consumption
it will last up to two weeks prunes
contain less sugar than dates so they
are a good option if you are looking to
keep the sugar content low I like to
carry one energy bar in my back in case
if I need a quick energy boost to keep
me going I have a healthy option to turn
to bear in mind that they are sticky but
so yummy so try this recipe and keep
experimenting with different
combinations let me know your favorite
combination in the comments below
I love soft baked cookies so I have to
look for a healthier option this mini
cookie dough balls are soft naturally
sweetened and made only with real food
the three main ingredients are one can
of chickpeas washed and drain
cut a cup of peanut butter and 2
tablespoons of maple syrup or honey
in a food processor mix in the chickpeas
peanut butter and maple syrup process on
high speed and to smooth and well
combined if you do not have a powerful
blender like me then you may need to
scrape off the side and just keep
blending you should have a rather smooth
dough but don't worry if it's a little
bit chunky
measure about one tablespoon of dough
roll and form into mini balls
this should make about 16 mini cookie
dough balls place them on baking sheet
or cupcake liners you may choose to
freeze them until solid or chill in the
fridge for a softer texture or just eat
immediately they are so good
chickpeas are used as the foundation to
this healthy cookie dough but don't
worry you can barely taste the chickpeas
peanut butter adds a slight nutty flavor
which can also be replaced with any nut
or seed butter of your choice each
cookie dough bites is only 49 calories
and if you want to you can even bake
them for a crunchy texture all these
recipes are super easy and versatile
with the three basic ingredients you can
jazz it up with all kinds of add-ins to
suit your tastes such as chocolate chips
chia seeds shredded coconut any nuts or
seeds and more I would also like to give
a shout out to the National Academy of
Sports Medicine & ASM for providing me
with a solid foundation to learn more
about Fitness food healthy living and to
share my knowledge and passion with you
guys so if you're interested in healthy
living or to help others to get healthy
the NASM is currently offering a 14-day
free trial to the online personal
training costs I have to share this
opportunity with you guys because I
think is a really good platform to
kick-start your fitness journey or
career so if you're interested linked
and more information is in my
description box and be sure to try all
these recipes let me know which is a
favorite in the comments below share and
like this video as well all the best
you